it's a failing country in real time and
that's why this is why Andrew is doing
so well his is so annoying hey guys Anna
welcome back to another video so today
I'm gonna be reacting to Andrew Tate's
latest interview with Piers Morgan I'm
sure it's going to be very juicy very
interesting so I'm really excited to get
into this before I jump into this don't
forget to hit the like button and if you
do like this kind of content and you
want to see more then hit the Subscribe
button this is Andrew Tate his last
interview with me has so far been viewed
well over 8 million times on YouTube
Alone 17 million times across all
platforms for someone who perhaps you're
watching and thinking who is Andrew T
well Andrew T joins me again good to see
it Compares good to see you I I've
genuinely been Amazed by the reaction
I've had in the streets not just here
but I went to Qatar for the World Cup
had the same thing there a lot of people
coming up about because John Ronaldo
obviously but also a lot of people
coming up about you and they were almost
exclusively men young men who genuinely
see you as a role model as somebody who
inspires them as somebody they want to
be like yeah so it made me think
first interview you have is quite
combative the second time a short
interview less so I want to try and work
out in this one who you are because it
struck me as extraordinary that Google
this week revealed some stats for the
year the number one person whose name
followed people Google searching who is
in 2022 was Andrew Tate yeah that's
quite remarkable I think there's a whole
swath of the population especially young
men that feel disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says to things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a Baskin
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution where perhaps you've done and
said stuff you shouldn't have done and
as you get older perhaps as you get
bigger more followed around the world
you sense a responsibility perhaps you
didn't have early on well we all evolve
every human evolves day by day you
wouldn't be human if you didn't evolve
on an hour-by-hour basis but I do not
think I'm a Force for good I absolutely
not really know I'm of course for truth
and truth is a good thing without truth
we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there I feel like we're starting
to combat it my cancellation was the
beginning of a change in public
Consciousness Elon having Twitter is
another beginning of the change in
public Consciousness and anybody who
stands up and speaks what they truly
believe even if it's something I don't
personally agree with I think that truth
is absolutely important and people's
personal truths and people's personal
opinions even on differing sides of the
same opinion should be heard yeah I
absolutely think Andrew is a Force for
good the world has become absolutely
crazy I think men need some kind of role
model that they can look up to we need
some kind of form of healthy masculinity
that men can apply to because I don't
really think there is anything right now
we have Jordan Peterson who's kind of
like a father figure but I think we need
that older brother who tells men that
it's okay to be themselves and I think
that's what Andrew's doing you were born
to a mixed race uh couple your father
was an African-American a chess player
yeah and your mother she was from this
country correct yeah so my father was
was black chess player he was in the Air
Force he met my mother here in England
and then I was raised initially in the
United States and then I moved to Luton
England when I was younger so I've moved
around a lot I've lived in Eclectic life
in many different scenarios we've moved
around I've done a lot of different
things a lot of different experiences
and uh how much currency are you I mean
would you identify I consider myself
British now but I will say that part of
me the Patriotic Britain side of me is
devastated by the state of the UK
currently and I want to make that very
clear the Patriotic Britain me truly
loves this country and seeing what's
happening to it especially to our major
cities is almost heartbreaking to watch
in real time in what way it's falling
apart is a failed Society by every
metric you can possibly measure it is
absolutely not really failing the cost
of living crisis the crime rates yeah
everything is falling apart if you
compare it to a country like the United
Arab Emirates you compare it to a city
like Dubai London which should be the
greatest city on earth is failing in
absolutely every metric because our
leadership is a joke if you look at
Dubai in the UAE the leadership there is
so Flawless so genuinely genius they saw
ahead and built almost a Utopia and then
you look at London you can't walk around
with a watch on it's disgusting I'm from
London and I left for a reason I just
saw a video of a woman getting arrested
she stood outside of an abortion clinic
quietly praying in her head and she got
arrested Lauren order in London in the
UK is an absolute joke the whole place
has got has become completely woke I
personally can't bear it don't blame
Andrew for leaving that's why I left
it's very interesting I was in Qatar for
the World Cup obviously a lot of people
in England taking a very sensorious
moral view about the World Cup being in
the Middle East at all because of their
laws against homosexuality because of
their treatment
not that I don't share the concerns
about those things of course I do but I
found a lot of The Virtue signaling and
I think that's what it was in many cases
yeah about the whole region actually
quite distasteful because when I was in
Qatar
a I thought the World Cup was
fantastically well run an incredibly
good experience but a lot of qataris
were saying to me you know there's this
weird quaint feeling back in your
country that we'll want to Aspire to
behave like that that we all want to
live in a country with massive drug
problems with massive knife crime issues
with scenes like the European
championships final where it's complete
lawlessness going on
um where
stuff like the NHS the system of
healthcare is basically collapsing where
the education system is dropping behind
so on and so on and so on it's a really
interesting perspective they were like I
know you all think that we want to have
your form of democracy in your form of
life but actually we're fine thanks it's
like Western entitlement people in the
west always think that they are the
center of the world and the West is the
way that everything should be but it's
not the level of crime is disgusting and
The Virtue signaling that we saw Around
the World Cup was unbelievable just
don't go the West is obsessed with
imposing it's ideologies on all these
other countries stay in America stay in
Europe if you don't like it don't go
nobody invited you to go and watch the
World Cup absolutely because it's a
failed society and it's Godless I think
it's disgusting we leave our old people
to rot in old people's homes yeah and
then we sit there and say we don't have
enough money for nurses I understand
this nurse strike very well on how
frustrating it can be if you walk into a
hospital the nurse is not prepared to
work but the nurses would be prepared to
work at the current wage if they believe
this country was spending his money
prudently when you see this country
spending its money in just absolutely
wasting it pulling out of thin air to
fund proxy wars God knows where that has
nothing to do with them of course as a
nurse you're going to stand up and say
well can I get a pay rise this country
has failed on every metric and how
especially our major cities I've just
come to London now I made it very clear
to my private jet pilot I said fuel the
Jet and leave it running because the
second I'm finished talking appears I'm
leaving this cesspit it's disgusting
this country and London as a whole 10
years ago was the one of the most
hospitable cities on earth now you
cannot walk around safely with a watch
on and you're a full-grown man you're a
full-grown adult when's the last time
there's been a serious problem in your
life that you completely ignored and it
fixed itself never ever what are any of
our politicians doing to fix any of the
problems
is planning to run again for the third
oh Sadiq Khan is like the worst thing to
ever happen to London so much virtue
signaling a few years ago there was a
poster of a woman in a bikini on the
London Underground and it said are you
Beachbody ready she looked super sexy
slim athletic stunning and Sadiq Khan
the mayor of London had that taken down
because it offended fat people that is
what we're dealing with we're not
dealing with reality we're dealing with
emotional children it's unbelievable why
don't you focus on making London better
focus on cry focus on making it just a
better City all I can say is I just
everyone I know who's had any experience
of crime at any level in London in the
last few years has had a bad experience
of it of the way it's been handled you
know I mean I can give an example I can
reveal this now I've talked for 18
months I've got a specific death threat
on one of my son's Instagram pages in
public a public comment and it was very
specific about what this person was
going to do I couldn't use the police to
evade him we we know where you live
we're going to come and kill you and
then the second one threatening uh my
son and his mother my ex-wife I called
in the police I'm not having them
putting death threats on my sons I
called the police police investigated
this they arrested somebody over a year
ago and then I heard from the police
this week that despite 18 months of
Investigation of a publicly posted
comment on Instagram threatening to kill
me uh on my son's Instagram that they
will not be able to pursue the case now
I thought imagine I'm high profile this
was a front page of the Sun newspaper
this is that same man called a
transgender person the wrong pronouns he
would be in trouble right so doesn't it
just show Absolutely how absolutely
asinine and banal our legal system has
become that would never happen in a
country like you never United Arab
Emirates the place I'm now residing in
Dubai where the leadership has common
sense and I'm saying that all the
leadership structures doesn't matter if
it's labor or conservative across all of
it in this nation of completely be
failed Sadiq Khan is a loser because
when you have a city which is losing
which London is is losing and all very
in all metrics across its competitive
cities around the world and you're in
charge of it by extension you're a loser
I will tell you right now instead of
virtue signaling and giving Qatar a hard
time over their religious beliefs what
we should be doing is a treaty with
Qatar to build a prison deep in the
desert yeah give me make me mayor of
London we'll make a prison deep in the
desert and if you're caught with a knife
or robbing someone you're good in 25
years with one meal a day in the in the
scorching sun and then what we'll do is
we'll put cameras there and we'll
interview you once a week to the nation
and see if you change your mind and make
people understand that this is a country
that should be respected and our law
should be respected instead what happens
what a city or any of the people in
charge of this country actually done to
fix any of our issues besides sit around
and talk nothing nothing none of them
have done anything but they seem Ultra
concerned with finding money for proxy
wars Ultra concerned with rainbow Flags
in another country that is uninterested
in them and their priorities are
completely messed up of course the
ambulance people are of course the
ambulance drivers are striking of course
the nurses are striking nobody cares
about the most important things in this
nation it's a failing country in real
time and that's why this is why Andrew
is doing so well this is why he's
uncancelable because he's actually
speaking facts the whole world has gone
so crazy this is literally what I'm
saying we need to go back to reality we
need Law and Order we need to put our
priorities straight people are so afraid
to speak of these things and of course
City Khan is a loser London is losing
entrepreneurs are leaving these amazing
people that would add value to any
economy don't want to add value to the
London economy we don't add value to the
United Kingdom because it's a collapsing
Society what about the specific
allegation by the way I don't disagree
with a lot of that um
he's in big trouble and I do think that
one of the problems is people think if
they do have a crime against them nobody
cares anymore they don't know I know
nobody cares I can I have specific
examples and people who I know
personally absolutely and utterly nobody
cares I was in Heritage yesterday and
someone tried to Rob someone's watch in
the middle of the store I walk around
with six full growth I have a security
team of six full-grown men plus me and
my brother eight damn military-aged
males all over 110 kilos big men just so
I can walk around this city it's
absolutely unacceptable what about the
issue of race and I mentioned that in
the context of the Harry and Megan
ongoing debate their war with the royal
family war against the monarchy the
specific uh constant uh referencing to
the fact that they believe they were
driven out of here because of racism in
Britain what do you make of that debate
that that's absolute fallacy yep and
you're from a mixed race correct
background yourself correct I'm from a
mixed race background myself and while
we're discussing the leaders of the UK
although I do think they're doing a
terrible job it's kind of hard for Megan
to say that the UK is a racist country
when the leader of the UK is darker
skinned than her and the layer of London
is darker skin than her and I am a
person who's probably darker skinned
than her and I've never experienced any
kind of bigotry against myself besides
the fact I'm a straight male I'm a
bigotry for that before I'll get bigotry
for my skin color I think it's just a
cop out and her not wanting to be
perspicacious and self-reflective enough
done understand that she has attacked an
age-old institution and there are people
who are very patriotic about that
institution and by attacking it and
bringing a degree of distaste to it
there's gonna be people who don't like
her and if you're a dislikable person
you can't just instantly stand up and
say it's because of my skin color it
might because be because of your actions
and some of the things you've said
Meghan Markle by the way is like a
typical woman she's just projecting her
emotions onto everybody else like she
refuses to take any form of
accountability for her actions how she
broke Royal protocol many different
things that she did which was just
unpleasant the way she used the media
the fact that she just throws the race
card out there no doubt she said racism
on social media because who hasn't it
well as I said I've read this on social
media no no one seemed to care very much
um but I think that's probably
inarguable my issue with what they've
both been doing is if you're going to
make allegations against an institution
not the royal family and the monarchy
you've got to actually provide some
evidence you can't just spray gun this
thing out there and say well somebody
was racist yeah and airing dirty laundry
is never going to be respected by the
populace and being a tattletale is never
going to be respected by the populists
and I think the problem with the modern
world we're living in is a lot of
age-old traditions are being destroyed
in real time it doesn't matter what the
tradition is most of them are being
eroded and something like the British
royal family which has been around for a
very long time is an age-old tradition
one of the things holding the UK
together one of the last things we have
to sit and detriment it and to sit and
insult it and to give away secrets from
inside of it and try and paint a
negative image of it is going to upset a
lot of people and you have to be
prepared for that backlash you can't say
I've done things to upset people but
it's nothing to do with what I've done
it's purely because of my skin color
also it's kind of ironic that she's
doing that because she's not
particularly dark skinned it's kind of
funny
I think the truth is I don't know what
look you can say that I can't
um
I just don't know what the specifics of
the racism she said she's had because
we've not seen any evidence the universe
is a funny Place Pierce if you're
looking for something you're going to
find it correct right when I got
canceled when they attacked me unfairly
lied about me across the entire
mainstream media deleted me from social
media so I couldn't defend myself and
lied about me repeatedly I could have
stood up and said it's because I'm Brown
I didn't do that I sat and said okay
there's people who misunderstand my
message my message is a positive one
people misunderstand me let me
self-reflect and understand that yes
perhaps this said a long time ago was
said in the wrong way perhaps this was
misunderstood perhaps people don't
understand this I could have just copped
out and could have just been refusing to
self-reflect on any level and said it's
because I'm Brown that's why they did it
but that's not the immature way to be as
an adult never trust the woman who pulls
you away from your family that's like
the biggest red flag for me with the
whole Harry and Megan thing as a woman
it's your job and it's your obligation
to ensure the family unit remains
together what kind of woman pulls a man
away from his brother father his
grandmother that's like such a red flag
for me no matter what your parents have
done or no matter what's happened to you
as a woman I think you should reconcile
that make the family come together way
she like insults his culture insults
where he comes from his Customs it's so
disrespectful that such a huge red flag
for a woman but when you attack an
institution as old as the British royal
family you're attacking patriotism in
and of itself it's also just his family
most respected countries or previously
most respected countries on Earth and
you're going to have some visceral
reactions perhaps Jeremy Clarkson is too
famous and too well renowned to say
those kind of things but there's a lot
of people who genuinely feel that way
and that's why he said it and this is
what happens when you attack age-old
institutions on any country should he
ever apologize that's a good question it
looks like he did personally I think as
a man you should stand up say what you
mean mean what you say I don't think you
should ever apologize for anything
you've ever said even me what if you say
something truly then very offensive and
you actually do regret it if you truly
regret it then yeah okay you can
apologize but if at the time you meant
it then the best thing you can do is say
look I've just changed my mind I no
longer feel that way but at the time
that's how I felt and I'm the person who
says what he feels and that's what I
felt at the time and I apologize I
offended you Genghis Khan had endless
women women and 200 children as a reward
for Conquest you tweeted on the most
searched man on the planet I've
conquered Earth on the highest status
mail on the planet females do not expect
loyalty from me they only expect that of
lesser men then there was this imagine
having less than 10 children because
you're a
H who doesn't careful why it's genetic
failures funny if a girl follows me and
she's hot and I see a single picture of
it a private jet it's block women can't
afford Jets women are all brokies why
are you flying around on some man's jet
you should have been a virgin when I met
you around all right Andrew Tate I feel
like he's says all this stuff for a fact
I thought he definitely means what he
says to some extent but he goes
overboard for a fact I take everything
he says with a pinch of Soul you know if
a woman like has a super rich dad and
then it's her father's private jet you
know new ones but as Andrew says
exceptions don't make rules he's getting
very near the knuckle with some of those
am I you tell me I don't think so I
think people can understand they're
semi-satirical they think people can
understand you mean them as jokes or do
you mean them don't they don't mean them
as jokes I mean they're a overall public
commentary and observation I do mean
what I say if I were to see a girl on a
private plane on Instagram for example I
would assume that a man put her on that
private plane I would not assume she
bought it herself well if it was perhaps
that makes me misogynistic what if it
was Ariana Grande or Beyonce well that's
slightly different isn't it why exactly
because they're famous yeah of course
like I said exceptions well like he says
but like I said exceptions don't make
rules and very rich but I don't think
that everyone if I saw one of them I saw
a 19 year old girl from Moldova where
the average wage is 200 a month and she
was on a private jet I would assume that
with the balance of probabilities
considering I'm an adult it's very
likely because of her beauty a man has
put her on that private plane yes yes
that makes me misogynistic instead of
just perspicacious enough to understand
how the world works then so be it I'm a
realist should you be such a generalist
about these things well you have to be a
generalist when you're looking for in
the balance of probabilities and tried
to find balance in the world you have to
be a generalist in general if I stroke a
lion it's going to bite my hand in
general there might be a nice one but I
don't want to find out so that's how the
world Works you've praised the Taliban
in the past would you do so again
tonight the world is not black and white
the world is gray it's very difficult to
sit and make black and white assumptions
about anything to sit and say that the
Taliban are completely inertly evil and
we're completely inertly good as you
just discussed with the moral High
Ground I believe that the Taliban bring
law and order it may not be the Law and
Order we like but it's a form of Law and
Order and humans usually gravitate what
about less treatment in women only
tonight only tonight they have banned
any women from going to University
fantastic let's get the feminists to go
and teach them a lesson the feminists
are so tough and they stand up and say
they can do anything a man can do let's
arm them up and send them to Afghanistan
I'm sure they'll fix it it's not it's a
it's a serious matter isn't it the women
don't that's education and that's a very
serious answer if women are just as
capable as men in terms of combat like
feminists pretend they are they can go
over there and they can deal with it a
lot of women do go to combat well
exactly so they can go deal with
talibans nothing to do with me they can
stand up and fight for their own right
surely you wouldn't defend the talent
ban Banning women from University it's
saying it's nothing to do with me Pierce
it's absolutely nothing what about the
Afghan women it's nothing to do with me
on any level you don't have a view I
have a view my view is that people
naturally gravitate towards Law and
Order and if you didn't have the Taliban
you'd have different Warlords operating
in lawlessness and there would be no way
to prevent your store your Market stall
getting completely robbed by someone
with an AK-47 and people are going to
gravitate towards a form of Law and
Order America left they left a power
vacuum and the power vacuum is now full
I don't disagree with that okay well I
do think I do think the Banning of
Women's University in Afghanistan is
utterly horrific and I think the
feminists are going to arm themselves
they're going to show us that they can
do anything a man can do they're going
to go over there to combat and they're
going to teach child of adolescents why
can't you just say on that you know what
it's completely wrong because it's not
my point is I don't understand but it
makes you mean it makes me think it'll
make your critics think that you don't
think it's wrong they could ban all men
they could ban all shorts but they're
not they're only Banning women correct
they could ban all short people they
could ban all people with long hair and
not if it's anything to do with me so
they can do whatever they want I'm not
going to go to war with the Taliban but
you've just literally spent an
impassioned first segment comparing the
way for example Dubai handles Law and
Order correct to this country correct so
you do Express views about different
laws absolutely both places so when I
put you a law that basically bans women
from being educated it's not why is it a
problem for you to say you know what
it's wrong there are both places I've
resided in London so I have personal
experience I can give my personal
opinion but like I said there's
absolutely nothing to do with me with
what the Taliban decide to do inside of
Afghanistan and they decide that's the
most prudent way to run their society
then we have two choices we can either
go over there and start another war that
we shouldn't be involved in and waste a
bunch of life or we can sit and say it's
up to them they should govern themselves
there are people we're no better than
them and they've decided to live their
lives a particular way and that's how
they're going to live it like I said if
feminists are very upset and they're
very disgusted by the fact that in
Afghanistan women cannot go to school
I've been told repeatedly by feminists
that they're just capable as men in all
realms I expect them to arm themselves
and fly over to Afghanistan and fix it
that is a really good point it is none
of our business this is what I was
saying earlier the West is so obsessed
with imposing its ideologies on all
other parts of the world and we don't
like it when they impose their
ideologies on us women being educated I
think it's important but I can also
understand the whole like let them be
let them do their thing because going in
and trying to fix it is only going to
cause Another War if you take them out
then you leave a power vacuum that's how
Isis was created like a lot of women
have done in combat that's good
congratulations go fight
well this is the thing that's very
interesting because when you talk about
ideas it's not even just about
Afghanistan and feminism you talk about
ideas they must all be defended at some
point there has to come down to violence
the world is backed by violence nobody
wants to talk about this it doesn't
matter what it is if you have a
disagreement between two parties
eventually the disagreement continues it
ends up in violence feminism is defended
by men men stand up and defend feminism
not feminists themselves because they're
incapable of violence and we're in a
situation now where you're saying that
we should send men to go and fight for
feminism why it's not a man's problem
I think well hey I think men can be
feminists too because oh no they can't
okay
I don't agree with radical feminists who
hate men right they do to me the radical
anything to me is a bad thing yeah and I
think most feminism in the west
currently is radical yes well some of it
is all of it is absolutely but that's my
point my point is that with the Taliban
are going to do whatever the Taliban
decide to do if I'm going to fly over to
another country I will respect their
laws and customs it's not my job to come
along and tell other people how to live
I don't believe I have a moral High
Ground in that degree and well people
are genuinely upset and disgusted by it
the bottom line and most disagreements
on the earth is violence people who feel
like they should go and fix it then fix
it with violence then it can be the
feminists who feel so outraged by it but
it's funny they don't comment on these
subjects feminists they seem to instead
attack the Western male for some reason
yeah you've deleted a video in which you
praised Isis why I don't know which
video you're talking about in particular
it might have been a video from a long
time ago but in general I understand
that like I said the world is not black
and white the world is gray areas and
Western imperialism as a whole has been
causing more problems than it's ever
fixed and it's disgusting and I don't
know the exact video You're referencing
but sometimes when an underdog destroys
a western imperialist I have a degree of
I wouldn't say satisfaction but every
satisfaction no but there's a there's
certainly a degree the way Isis I don't
know the particular I don't know about
the particular video we're talking about
Isis were one of the most deadly Terror
groups in the world absolutely they
committed a series of appalling
atrocities sure that's if you even
believe any of that like I don't know
you know the whole Ariana Grande concert
the bombing that happened in Manchester
England that was supposedly Isis
I don't know if I believe that was
supposedly I said killing innocent
people left right in the center how
could you possibly have satisfaction
well if it's the video I'm recollecting
it's about the fact that I believe that
Isis was funded by the Western created
by the West in the first time
satisfaction like I'm happy Isis exists
it was a commentary on the world well
here's what you said Isis are the real
Muslims because I assist you exactly
what the book says kill everyone is not
a Muslim and chop people's heads off and
set them on fire and be ready but all
the other Muslims go they're not real
Muslims because I read the book and
ignore those parts well then you're not
an effing Muslim because you're ignoring
the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes and then you come to a
realization and you start to learn the
truth of yourself and the truth of God
and you realize that religion is
actually the cure for most of the
problems in the world and godlessness is
the problem in the world so that is
something I will apologize for to me I
was wrong about because I was atheistic
and now as a Muslim I understand that's
absolutely not the case if that's a
particular video you're talking about
then then well that's really interesting
so you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said at the time I believed
it because I didn't believe in God at
the time it was a very long time ago
it's actually kind of a testament to you
peers you managed to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed but at the time I was atheistic
well no I was curious because you have
recently converted to Islam correct so
these questions are thinking pertinent
to your conversion absolutely as to what
you actually believe as a practicing
Muslim now uh yeah I believe that Islam
is beautiful I believe it's the last
True Religion on Earth it's certainly
the last respected religion on Earth and
I felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today
that particular video was once again
satirical a lot of people watching this
would not have seen it they would not
seen the joke element of it it's fine it
but it's not funny though well you know
it's like most of the time as we
discussed in our first interview with me
things are taken out of context short
form etc etc but
all in all you could say the same things
about Christians if you were to read the
Old Testament and say stick to the Old
Testament you'd kill anyone who works on
a Sunday so it's not applicable you
wouldn't countenance violence second you
don't countenance violence I absolutely
do not countenance violence when I was
talking about violence being the bottom
line salute the bottom line decider
between
disagreeing points of view it's not I'm
calling for violence I'm just making a
commentary on how the world generally
functions from what I understand that's
basically saying violence is always the
threat in the background if you break
the law then you have to go to jail and
if you refuse to go to jail then they
physically grab you and if you refuse to
obey with whatever they ask of you in
jail then it gets violent violence is
the backbone of society I'm not saying
that's how it should be I'm just saying
that's the reality because if you don't
do as you're told there's a threat of
violence behind everything when you use
a word like satisfaction
you understand that people will watch
that and think how can you possibly find
any form of terrorism satisfying I don't
find any form of Terror satisfying I
don't find Western terrorism satisfying
either I don't think it's satisfying
that we managed to find five hundred
thousand dollars per bomb to drop on
some farmer who makes four dollars a day
under the name of freedom and and we
can't seem to pay our nurses enough to
do their jobs I don't want any kind of
terrorism and it's actually very
interesting to talk about the world
terrorism terrorist and freedom fighter
good guy and bad guy all of this is
subjective there are people who believe
that the west of the biggest terrorists
on the Earth are people who believe that
America causes more Wars than anyone
else more people than anyone else
there's people who believe the absolute
opposite so once again it depends who
you're talking to is the subjective
conversation there's no black and white
in the world there's areas of gray and
that's how it is so I thought you were
talking about another video where I was
saying that Isis is standing up and
fighting for what they believe in I'm
not saying what they believe in is right
but that's what they were fighting for
at the time and it was a completely
different video than the one you were
actually referencing I remember a time
not so long ago when they said
unvaccinated people were evil were
killing grandmas we now have a pandemic
of the unvaccinated so you could call
unvaccinated people terrorists just
based off of some crazy perspective you
can speak out and suddenly you're a
threat to National Security and then the
government can come in do whatever they
want in the name of National Security
um and in the name of terrorism wasn't
it um Justin Trudeau who called
unvaccinated truckers terrorists I think
he said it was a domestic terrorism I'm
pretty sure he said that using the word
terrorist is a bit like using the race
card the sexism card it's a way to shut
down a whole perspective and you would
condemn them now I don't condemn anybody
doing anything bad to anybody I I'm not
a person out here with a criminal record
I don't hurt anyone I just spent my
first
segment on this show talking about how I
believe in Law and Order yeah how
important that is I think people can
operate inside of their lives safely and
walk around man woman child can walk
around in safety in any City they live
in how that Law and Order is constructed
is not my
jurisdiction I'm not in charge of the
Law and Order of of Afghanistan
Tajikistan Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan
Kazakhstan any of them there's nothing
to do with it Andrew take you or you're
interviewing about Free Speech thinks
women are a man's property we shouldn't
be allowed to drive both should be Iraq
misogynists are disgusting whether
they're an Afghanistan or a Swanky
London Studio
am I a misogynist am I I don't think I
the first thing to think she said I
don't even truly believe it's I can if
you're prepared to listen to me I'll
explain to you exactly why she's not
really completely utterly wrong yes if
you can go through the points again do
you think you're a misogynist absolutely
not I'm not a misogynist on any level
this is one of those buzzwords they
throw it they just throw at people
randomly homophobic races misogynistics
throw it out at people what is your
viewers I'm a realist what's your real
view of women I absolutely not really
love women I adore women I have good
relationships with women not a single
woman has come up to me on the street
since I've been canceled not a single
one has said anything negative every
single one of them has said positive
things you're a traditional male I wish
more men were like you you understand
your masculine roles you understand what
you're supposed to do you understand
you're supposed to protect women you're
exactly the kind of man I've been
looking for I've never had a negative
interaction with a female ever since
I've been dubbed the biggest massages
where is the please please let me finish
I'm sorry sorry Pierce also there's not
been a single woman who's accused me of
a crime not a single woman's accused me
of rape not single woman's come out and
said anything from my entire past of 36
years I've done anything wrong ever
anybody else with my level of Fame any
football or any other movie star at
least has people who've come out and
accuse him of rape XYZ I have no woman
who's come out and ever since I've hurt
her no woman has come out and ever said
I've done damage to her or been horrible
to her everybody who ever interacted
with me has said I've been a nice person
all of them so this random Twitter
nobody who seems to know so much is full
of all right you've responded to her
Twain yeah where is the line for you
between masculinity which I will always
defend and which I agree with I think a
lot of women like men to be masculine
yeah we do what has become known as
toxic masculinity the reason I ask you
is that you are engaged in that debate
with men all the time where is the line
for you where men shouldn't cross where
the behavior should be kept within a
line before he even answers like it's
just obvious don't abuse women don't
rape women don't hit women I don't
understand how it's just not common
sense what masculinity is and should be
how can peers even ask that question
please define toxic masculine well you
tell me what you think it crosses a line
from being a masculine good man to a bad
man there's no such thing as too much
masculinity if it's genuinely masculine
masculinity he's not out here to hurt
people's absolutely the opposite it's
out here to protect and when bad things
happen they call traditionally masculine
men if you need a firefighter you need a
masculine man when you call the police
because of the problem you have you want
masculine men and as soon as a woman or
a man is in trouble when you look for
backup you look for masculine men and
masculine men have a duty to provide and
protect those they care about we have a
duty to do things we don't feel like
doing because we know we're supposed to
do them yeah and that's why we stayed in
the Titanic and died those were
masculine where did you get your views
about this from what do you mean your
views like that's what masculinity is I
don't get it like that's what
masculinity is and yes you can never
have too much masculinity it's just so
weird what part of masculinity is okay
and what part of masculinity isn't okay
oh well like the rape part isn't okay
that's not masculinity that's an abusive
individual because what I grew up with
it's the family I grew up around the
father your mother yeah and the world I
lived in and I think a lot of the things
I'm saying now about masculinity and how
people should act in the world how the
world should function we're considered
completely normal and accepted by
everybody only 20 years ago I think the
world is very true for me to stand up
and say a man should protect a woman now
gets to be called a misogynist and
canceled if I said that 10 years ago
women and what's funny is everyone who
argues against me and says men shouldn't
protect women especially all the
feminists if they were with their
boyfriend and a man broke into their
house guess who they'd expect to go
downstairs the man
who do you think think they go
themselves no are they going to
Afghanistan no we send men to do these
things we send women in the armed forces
too oh please you have to generalize
when you make points there are many many
exceptions exceptions do not disprove
the rules you've got to concede there
are many courageous women serving the
Army absolutely I feel like peers agrees
with everything Andrew is saying he's
just being peers hang devil's advocate
for views absolutely and utterly
completely correct but by and large
traditionally soldiers are men
exceptions do not disprove the rule yes
well it's not an exception it's a fact
that there are a lot of women
if you were to take the average Soldier
they are a male
if you're allowed to say who's a male
and who was assuming their gender I
apologize if you ever take the average
Soldier they're a male which means that
exceptions are the female soldiers which
because there's a lower percent of them
a lower probability exceptions do not
disprove the rules men do the fight
right now in Ukraine men cannot leave
women are allowed to leave because men
have to fight in the front line and
women are allowed to go to Dubai that is
how it is are women allowed to go on
yachts in Dubai I love that what do you
say to young men who come to you for
advice you feel lost you don't really
know where they fit into society I say
that life as a man is exceptionally
difficult I say the most beautiful and
the most terrifying thing about being a
manager born without value Society
doesn't care about you you're only going
to be cared about based on how useful
you are you have the chance to build
yourself up and become a superhero if
you're prepared to do the hard work and
be indefeatable enough to never quit but
if you're going to stand around and wait
for a handout nobody's going to ever
respect you and I think that a lot of
people have forgotten about how
difficult and how competitive it is as a
man always in constant competition with
each other and it's your duty as a man
to stand up and say I want to be as
important and strong and good-hearted
and God-fearing as possible and I need
to work hard to achieve those things
Dame Sheila Hancock says we've become
too over emotional as a society crying
too much about everything well she got a
point she's completely right and the
dangerous thing about overly emotional
men is that they're dangerous they're
genuinely dangerous this is what's crazy
all these people talk about toxic
masculinity and how bad it is for men to
be traditionally masculine a
traditionally masculine man does things
he doesn't feel like doing because it is
his duty to do them he charges into the
burning building because it is his duty
not because he feels like it because it
is his duty we're now teaching the new
generation of men that they don't have
duty and they can just act on their
feelings and act how they feel and they
don't have to act as a man should you
know what happens when you get men who
just act how they feel you get School
shooters you get violence you get
rapists men who do not control their
emotions are dangerous if you find a man
who is stoic he's not going to hurt
people yeah he's going to sit and think
about his actions very carefully and
he's gonna be a good man who protects
for it and provides for his family you
find a man who just acts out on impulse
and does whatever he feels like you're
going to find a dangerous man sitting
here telling men to cry more and act
with their feelings and it's okay to
feel this way that way Etc have no
self-control that is why we have the
problems we have in the world correct
absolutely nothing wrong so when they
talk about toxic masculinity they have
it completely inversed on its head
completely nutly wrong we need to be
teaching stoicism we need to be teaching
young men to understand that the world
is very very difficult it's hard to be a
man you're going to feel bad sometimes
you just suck it up and perform anyway
don't just sit there you cry your eyes
out or blame other people talk about
them too in modern systems certainly
tough being a woman but I'm not a woman
so why would I speak on issues I do not
understand I'm a man you can feel them
empathy for women I feel empathy
certainly but I do not understand their
issues a lot of men come up to me and
they admire you I've got to say a lot of
women I've spoken to don't admire they
think you represent misogyny they think
when they hear you not commit and they
can't even Define misogyny if you look
at my other videos I ask all these women
what do you think about Andrew Tate oh
my God hate him he's a misogynist can
you give me an example also can you
define misogyny please crickets saying
the Taliban shouldn't be banning women
from University education why can't he
just say that's wrong well firstly
that's not my experience I experience
the absolute yeah
secondly it's because it's a moral point
I'm making my moral point is I speak on
things I understand I speak on
experiences I've had but you believe in
equality I speak yes sure I speak on
subjects I know intimately I do not feel
qualified I'm a realist and I do not
feel qualified to sit and discuss the
gender laws in Afghanistan I have not
been to Afghanistan I have not
researched the subject thoroughly I'm
not going to sit here and say how they
our Taliban should be running their
country it's nothing to do with me I
find it quite flattering peers that
although you know I understand I'm
monumentally influential the most Google
man on Earth Etc I find it very
flattering that you think I have some
kind of control over the domestic policy
of Afghanistan but I assure you I don't
I don't no no there's nothing to do I'm
not asking you to have a view on having
influence of a domestic policy I'm sure
the Taliban couldn't give us stuff what
either of us say about it um it's just
curious to me that it's an easy win for
you to make women think you're not anti
them to say that when they're not given
a quality as the women in Afghanistan
clearly are not because they're not
allowed to go to university as of today
that is clearly unequal unfair we should
all be able to agree that that is wrong
well certainly as a reason even you
tough guy Andrew he's not tough guy I am
a professional as a professional I can
state that yes it is not equal yes it is
not fair that is obvious for anybody but
like I'm not saying those things are not
true what I'm saying is it's nothing to
do with me right okay but you've made a
concession you think is wrong it's wrong
I said it's unequal and it's unfair yeah
so wrong well perhaps force yourself
Andrew no perhaps it's wrong under
certain moral guidelines but under the
moral guidelines which are currently in
charge of the jurisdiction of
Afghanistan they don't believe it's
wrong it's nothing to do with me well
then I'm not going to sit here until
other countries how to run their laws
I'm going to live in societies
you know what I'll take unfair and
unequal sure because that's
self-explanatory or to your ancestors
what would you have made of your success
your father he would be extremely
underwhelmed by it because he always
expected it out of me my memory Andrew
take the third I can do whatever I put
my mind to and he would be like well of
course you decided you want to become
the most famous man on the planet it
took you a few months of course does
your does your mother ever do what my
mother does and occasionally go I think
you went too farther my mother has
absolute trust in my abilities and
capabilities she says be careful do your
best but you are the most capable and
competent man on the planet that wasn't
the question that's what she says she
says be careful does she ever say you
shouldn't have said that nah she knows
better than that no never she says
you're just be careful you know what
you're doing it's kind of hard to argue
against me and this is what my haters
seem to struggle with it's hard to argue
against the person who is monumentally
successful in every single human metric
that can possibly be measured this is
why young men respect me so much would
you ever tell your mother what they want
to be my life I don't need to she's a
full grown woman would you ever tell her
what to do I would give her my advice if
she asked first you say you can't leave
the home you can't drive all those
things okay this is so annoying I feel
like he's just like purposely
misinterprets everything Andrew Drew
says give her my I'd give her my opinion
I would say perhaps you should move
house now or perhaps that's not safe or
yeah I would absolutely because I'm
responsible for her safety and when
you're responsible for somebody's safety
you have an opinion and you need to have
a firm opinion on that and that's right
completely for any woman I am
responsible for for any woman I'm
responsible for her safety I will sit
and say that's an unsafe thing to do how
much are you worth I'm a billionaire by
now dollars or pounds about dollars
we're not in pounds yeah we'll get there
so what to do
yeah we have a little bit of work to do
but finally I know you don't know
anything about football and carry the
list but greatest of all time Ronaldo or
Messi they're both two very hard-working
men I have absolute respect for anybody
on Earth who dedicates themselves
all right well that was so interesting
Pierce just does my head and I feel like
Pierce genuinely believes Andrew and
agrees with Andrew but he can't help
this Western kind of ideologies that's
so ingrained within him and so many
people as always I support Andrew I
think he's doing a great good for
Humanity for women and for men we need
more masculine men and I want to be
clear there's no such thing as toxic
masculinity there's just toxic
individuals we need masculinity back we
need men who understand their Duty which
will then create a beautiful space for
women to be feminine be nurturing to be
kind and to be soft and raise the Next
Generation so that's my overall take if
you enjoyed this video please don't
forget to hit the like button and hit
subscribe so you can see more of this
kind of content I have a lot of amazing
podcasts dropping really soon so
definitely stay tuned